boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation i'm your host don sakyon very
very excited for this episode we are
still on site in boston massachusetts we
are at the new research building in dr
george church's office we are going to
be talking about all things synthetic
biology and his lab and what's going on
for us in this new evolution of our
future george thank you so much for
joining us on the show my pleasure
greatly appreciate it um this is our
second episode of george the first one
was super short
at arc fusion and i'm really glad that
i've had more time to study up for this
one and we're going to go into a little
bit more depth on a lot of the really
important fields that you're working in
for those that don't know
george church is a geneticist a
molecular engineer a chemist he is a
professor at harvard and mit last 33
years this is it's an incredible amount
of students in teaching that's been
going on he runs the church lab which
has a hundred people it's grown over 33
years to have a hundred people working
within the church lab on a bunch of
different uh disciplines of uh advancing
us into the future so he's co-founded 22
companies
co-authored 500 papers 143 patent
publications author of regenesis and so
much more
george you have an insanely incredible
bio you have been at the edge of
knowledge for so long pushing the
boundaries so this is an honor thank you
thank you thank you so
all right let's let's start with this
big history understanding of where we
found ourselves kind of as stewards of
earth and figuring out now tweaking the
biology so this is a major transitionary
moment how have you seen that evolution
of civilization up until this point of
synthetic biology
well that's a obviously big question uh
but uh
i think one of the things that that
critics often point out is we make
mistakes and there's no doubt about it
we are a species of engineers that is
that is both our
uh
that's our past and our futures almost
certainly has to do with
our unique ability to really think
deeply about the past and the future and
to engineer as a consequence we we do
make mistakes but we're probably only
species that is capable of protecting
any or all of the species from
catastrophic events like
asteroids the sun expansion
etc so
we have that responsibility to ourselves
and many other species uh and maybe to
the whole universe we there is still yet
an open question as to whether we're the
only intelligence uh
in the in the entire universe is i mean
it's it's arrogant to think of it either
way that we're the that we're the only
one or that we're one of a billion you
know it's it's just
it's arrogant to think we know the
answer to that yeah yeah
lots of civilizational hubris and
you you point out that we have a lot of
sort of
ways of figuring out how to best use
these powers and you point out to
um to species and i and i actually
wanted to make this point as you are
investigating how to do things like
bring the woolly mammoth back into at
least a point of awe within our own
awareness there's so many species that
we could bring back as a point of awe
and as an awareness expansion for
ourselves to be able to see how we got
to this point is that kind of where that
drive for the species comes from well so
i think the woolly mammoth is the best
example of something where we can get
more than just awe i mean all is
amazing already but
uh we can we can get things that are
potentially beneficial
to the species they're
and and to species preservation in
general the species being asian elephant
by bringing in
other bits of dna that could help it
survive in the modern world
but also to help
the arctic environment where they can
participate in carbon sequestration
which can benefit the entire planet
preventing carbon loss and sequestering
new carbon
so when we think about species you know
de-extinction we're typically talking
about the extinction of genes almost all
animal plants and animals and bacteria
are hybrids of related
organisms and we're creating a
particular hybrid which will be cold
resistant asian elephants it'll extend
their range it'll help help them help us
with carbon sequestration
so see there's there's many ways to
engineer to
advance our world like you said carbon
sequestration is one of them they're awe
there's so many of these different ways
to to help advance us
now i want to ask you know as we kind of
dive into the the deeper subject areas
prior to getting there
you know what what you did with in 1975
with x-ray crystallography of transfer
rna and seeing how that
how that affects the
carrying of instructions to other parts
of the cell
that was kind of a big moment for you
and that was at the cutting edge of
knowledge and you've spent the next
40 years at the cutting edge plus years
at the cutting edge of knowledge always
pushing always pushing the edge of what
we know
tell us about that
it's not just knowledge there's also
engineering uh but yeah the transfer rna
that was a teenager when i was first
introduced to this research project uh
my sunko kim and his team
and uh
i
um i was doing i started that was just a
job but it was one that i picked i mean
i didn't you know to to be uh the fusion
of math physics chemistry biology
um computer science all in one package
because you really had to have all of
those to to
it's not like looking through a
microscope where you just see things you
actually have to solve the structure
but it also introduced me the whole
world of nucleic acids
and i you know the epiphany of typing in
all of the sequences that were known at
the time the one-dimensional structures
folding up at the three dimensions and
then
seeing how it is how easy that was
and and how valuable it would be to have
the one-dimensional structure of
everything in the world
it also introduced me
to automation so we had all that data
was automatically collected this in 1974
and almost nothing was computerized or
automated in the rest of the
rest of biology and i thought well
time to
to introduce that um and there were many
other aspects of it you know first
folded rna first fold into click acid uh
it was uh
led me to a lot of almost everything
we're still working on has to do with
that and we still work on even transfer
rna itself and the genetic code changing
genetic codes of a number of organisms
now
and
george was
a pioneer in
genome sequencing and still is
in genome sequencing and you've seen
that drop
in
in price and speed so we are now doing
things much faster and much more cost
effectively and you've co-founded
several companies in the space
veritas genetics nebula genomics so
teach us about what's happening because
you're specifically making a big push to
the idea of
open access mechanisms because there's a
lot of silos of data and we want to be
able to leverage open access to data in
safe ways that make it easier for
medical research yeah
exactly so there were there were two
components from the very beginning for
me one was the technical part of
bringing down the cost and we've
you know pursued most recently
fluorescent next-gen sequencing and
nanopores to help do that we brought
down 10 million fold in cost
but at least that technical part there's
a social component which is
convincing people is safe and that it's
effective you know that it does
something that they care about
um and the problem is it's kind of a
seat belt situation where even after the
seat belts were installed in your car is
effectively free
and even there were laws and so forth to
really get people to pay attention
you had to have a circuit that sensed
that your seat belt was was sealed and
then they would shut off the annoying
sound
and i think we have a similar thing here
where about one percent of the people
are at risk for genetic diseases
and they sort of feel like well i'm
exempt because there's nobody in my
family yet but the thing is that's
almost always the scenario is there's
nobody in your family until there is one
um
so uh so what veritas and
nebula do is veritas brought the price
down to thousand dollars and started
getting it out
to
closer to regular people
but nebula brings it down to zero
dollars and starts
making the connection to researchers
like pharmaceutical companies
much more friction free
um simultaneously
making convincing arguments that that
they're to to lower what
the two things that worry people want is
the safe you know is there is there data
secure and nebula can using combination
of blockchain encryption we can
guarantee that the data is only used the
way you originally wanted to be used you
can you can secure it so that
your physician can't see it insurance
companies can't see it can't be
subpoenaed because you actually you
never actually had it nobody else has it
it can only be used for a list of things
that you approved in advance that could
benefit you and nothing's going to be
held against you and you don't need you
can even protect it from yourself so you
don't learn anything that you don't want
to learn
so
that's a that's a breakthrough and then
the the breakthrough of getting the drug
companies to pay for your genome and
even maybe possibly paying you for the
education and time
um
completely blows away the thousand
dollars you know with
um
making something where you could
potentially profit from your genome
without ever
actually selling it to anyone
the
the importance as you said of of privacy
for an individual's full genome sequence
and then to
have these access controls where we
ourselves can decide where we want the
data to flow and who we want to help
plus then not only have that be a free
of cost for us to understand our whole
genome but then for medical research to
be able to be done
on how we can best
help with diseases and all different
types of understandings of of different
humans
this is a crucial advancement and it's a
new way of thinking about things of
offering offering data which is this
most precious and also
one of the best ways to better
understand ourselves uh giving that in a
safe way to researchers and then letting
them
better understand
humans and also potentially get paid and
this could potentially be a good way to
get into something like a universal
basic income is giving our data and then
being able to get paid for that right
yeah
it's exciting stuff and that is
i love your push for that though these
open axis mechanisms it's it's very very
cool that your silos are very
problematic at both ends they're neither
that they're uh
they don't benefit the patient much
they it's very hard to uh to get in
uh when you get in what you can do with
it is very limited um and so
at the very open end of the spectrum is
the personal genome project and then at
the
at the level where almost anything could
be uh
communicated without anyone ever having
your individual genome in their
possession
in an encrypted form the normal way that
you you encrypt use encryption is
i'll send you a encrypted email you'll
uncr you decrypt it at the other end
but at that moment it it's it's out of
my hands and it's in its full embodiment
that you're in but with things like
homomorphic encryption you can ask
questions of a group of us and get your
data back without ever without you or
anyone outside of my control ever having
my open
genome so
you can ask the same questions you would
ask but they're all the questions and
answers are all
via this encryption
this this leads us into another
pressing area that that you're working
on
we've seen over the last
six or so years this
this evolution of of crispr into our
lives of of better
leveraging evolutionary technologies for
over billions of years like bacteria
so with the cast nines ability to go in
and do things like genetic editing
and engineering that is birthing this
new there's a second wave that's coming
now of genetic engineers leveraging
crispr's cast nine but also other like
sc cast nine so there's new sorts of
ways to uh to
i want you to
tell us about this second wave because
you guys have a good amount of second
waivers in your lab and you're pushing
the the edge again in genetic
engineering
yeah
i would say it's probably you know
eighth wave or something like that
because there there were many
genome editing methods before crispr and
there'll be probably many after
and uh christopher's not even that good
at doing precise editing where you where
you want to say change
uh
a g to a t that's very hard to do
with crispr
single point um that you're right it can
make single point mutations but sort of
randomly and and sometimes it hits
adjacent bases that you didn't want to
touch
and and and that uh
there there were ways there have been
other ways to do that so for example
there's a lambda red system that allows
you to do that there's a aav single
stranded dna based method there are a
bunch of uh
integrases where you can pop in a
cassette precisely and then you've got
the point mutations in that cassette so
these are only slightly less efficient
than crisper right at the moment
and they will inevitably get they'll
everything will get easier and cheaper
and at that point you will pick the ones
the best and that's been the history
with sequencing too is that everything
is there were all kinds of compromises
and shortcuts and so forth and those
have fallen away now that
you'll just pick the best sequencing
right now which is whole genome
sequencing
yeah so i listed some of the ones that
are that are
that are precede crispr and those same
ones are up and coming because they
could blow past it because of their
precision
it was so interesting how you were like
no alan this is the eighth wave
[Laughter]
okay and the because this is what was it
tau right t-a-l so tau was the the one
just before crispr and it's still in use
it's still in clinic it's in clinical
trials um people use it for research um
just like you can send off an order to
get crispr in other words nobody
actually almost nobody makes crispr in
their own lab what they'll do is they'll
order
the synthetic uh
modifications and then they'll come back
in and then they'll do the experiment in
their lab
and same thing with towels you order and
it comes back in the prices are not that
different um
and so in the end it's going to be which
one handles the sequence you want so so
everything there are regions that many
are using the genome where none of the
known crisprs will cut there okay but
the towels are uh basically you can make
one to cut anywhere yeah and that's
that's an advantage so in terms of
precision yeah and this is what we're
looking at aiming to be able to a
hundred percent of the genome rather
than just the limited i think it's close
to what 70 percent or so
and the and the other
advantage uh
or the other thing we're looking for for
the next next generation is ability to
do multiple sites at once
so if right now if we're having problems
doing one in other words for having on
target and off target problems if you do
two sites three sites
we get down to 15 000 sites
then you need to have something that's
very low toxicity and very
precise and so that's another that's
another standard measurement for how
well we're improving is is how high a
multiplex level we can get to well
multi-targeting
because yeah just quickly um off
targeting is when you're looking at a a
sequence of of dna that looks similar to
where you and it accidentally goes there
and then um on target what are how can
you have an on target error on target
meaning you're trying to change
uh uh you're trying to make a precise
edit like a g to a t
and you and you make a little bit bigger
uh so you could call that off target off
by one but it's basically it's on target
so right gene
and uh okay uh it's just not it's not
very precise on target so off target is
completely different part of the genome
not even in the in a related gene
and in our very first paper where we
turn crisper into technology
we
anticipated that we wrote computer
programs that would help you avoid off
target because i think it's easy to just
naively say oh i'm going to
use the computer to design it to hit
this gene and you ignore it but you need
to think holistically you need to think
about whole genomes that's what we did
yes in our very first paper
now george give us your understanding of
there's this is part of bacterial
evolution we're now starting to see
billions of years of the of what they've
understood as best
uh ways to boost up their own immune
systems we're trying to understand what
they're doing and apply that to
ourselves
and we're trying to use computational
biology to really best
understand a lot of this so can you tell
us what your thoughts are about
leveraging computational biology to
better you do genetic engineering
right so there's
we use computational biology in almost
every aspect of everything every
research we do this is just one of them
so it can be used for computer aided
design
certainly you need to
to edit the genome you need to be able
to read it up front you need to know
what it is you're editing and at the end
you need to read it again to make sure
what you edited was what you wanted
right
so
there's a lot of computational uh
components there you need to go through
you need to get inspiration from
somewhere so you need to look through
human populations for people that are
exceptionally resistant to diseases
you need to look for people that you
know the contribution to common diseases
look at animals
for
um and and bacteria for additional yeah
tools that you can use
um so all of us computational
interesting yeah yeah
so exactly computational biology being
leveraged into all different aspects of
the lab and also
um
the
sort of
without getting too much into the um
ethics and the in the geopolitics of
things um you are is your most is your
we've now through through evolution
we've been
we've been doing our own uh genetic
engineering through through breeding
over time and it's taken much longer now
we can go immediately and start tweaking
we can eradicate disease we can do
augmentations to humans
which are do you have a specific kind of
favorite that you're most interested in
in the space
well so the the most powerful
preventative medicine
which is also augmentation
that uh that
we should all be familiar with which we
should be constantly celebrating is
vaccines we have about a couple dozen
vaccines that make us superhuman
relative to our ancestors they lived in
fear
of
you know a small pox of polio of
many diseases that we now have
or not fearful of
because
they're either completely extinct
nearly extinct or
completely controlled by the vaccination
process
that in principle some of that
could there could be similar things that
happen that increase our health over our
lifetime there could be gene therapies
for example that could reverse aging as
we get older
there can be some that have cognitive
advantages as we get older so that we
prevent the cognitive decline in a
population that's
uh rapidly becoming kind of lopsided on
the on the older end of this of the
demographic spectrum
we could have
you know a cognitive enhancement to
reduce that cognitive decline
and uh and who knows where we go from
there but those are examples of things
where
genetics is not fundamentally different
from drugs except the connections
between mechanism and therapy is so much
more direct and faster and so we
we need to
they'll go through the normal
vetting processes of safety and efficacy
through the fda the ema cfda and so
forth
and then you started touching on
on neuroplasticity and neurodegeneration
and so i wanna you have brain initiative
going on you have the um connectome
going on and so this is mapping all of
the neural pathways and neural networks
within our entire nervous system this is
very exciting uh teach us about why this
is so important
so
the brain is is very special in many
ways it's one of the things that
separates us from other animals their
ability to
to think about the past the future
to you know uh it's not just memory it's
our ability to
to uh think out of the box to uh intuit
to emote
um
to show sympathy
and all of that's
uh we could another thing that makes it
unique is you can replace almost any
part of your body i mean as we go into
the future
organ transplants will become
very easy
but it's hard to place certain parts of
your brain that are responsible for the
memories that make you you
um so we want to learn more about how
that's encoded
and we want to do it
inexpensively
something that could be used clinically
where we know the connection of every
you know every neuron might be connected
to a thousand other neurons you know 36
billion neurons each with a thousand
connections or big range
and
and whether those connections are
inhibitory or excitatory
we can map out this at molec single
molecule level so we could really go
down to a resolution of of the synapse
and we we have
[Music]
a big government project uh
from irpa called the microns project
that it aims for synapse revolution
resolution connectome
plus we can find out what the lineage of
the cells were you know what cells begat
you know what precursors be we became
those cells where they migrated
and what and what their expression state
is which again is relevant to
understanding and if you had
that kind of deep understanding you
could reconstruct
it if it got broken yeah potentially
and we're going to start with very
simple things like dopamine and
parkinson's but eventually we'll get to
more be able to reconstruct more and
more complicated connectomes so we have
to again have to read and write the
the brain cells
and not just neurons but clia
yeah you know
oligodendrocytes and so on yeah
wow all the way down to the
to the
to the small even to the synaptic level
right yeah wow
so we have super resolution with
multiple
high quality antibodies that can tell us
pre and postsynaptic excitatory
inhibitory at the synaptic level
connector whoa
and this is getting a lot deeper than
just knowing prefrontal cortex amygdala
this is way
way cool and deep yeah um and then now
this is this is actually ties us into
the importance of
preservation we've gotten this far as a
civilization in many regards due to
collective learning that we've been able
to build on top every single millennia
up until this point and so now as we go
with minds like you we want to retain as
much as we can of of what's built up in
your mind over time and then be able to
tap into that in the future and access
it and understand how you got to where
you got and whatnot
yeah
and
how how specifically um
are
are you working on um your own
uh
neuroplasticity as well as offsetting
moving yourself away from
neurodegeneration
yeah i don't i don't think of it so much
as about me i mean i was taught
as a youth to serve everybody else first
that's right but we need you to george
we need you i i think there is a
a bit of a tragedy that occurs among
many uh highly skilled people is that
it really takes a lifetime a current
lifetime to get to a point of competence
you know i think that i didn't feel
particularly competent until i hit my
64th birthday and now i actually feel
like i can do my job because i've been
properly educated it would be a pity to
like build this and program the super
computer and then unplug it the sec the
day that it's that it's finally working
uh and that's
um you know i've already uh twice the
age average age of my ancestors uh you
know that our longevity has doubled
roughly um
and it's and it's more and more
occurring at the later years of life so
if we could extend
the youthful
ness of the body this regenerative
properties that you see
most diseases that kill us in
industrialized nations
um do not kill 20 year olds
and so that sort of planned obsolescence
if we can reverse it
then we can have all the advantages of
this
education
60 years of education
plus the flexibility of mind that you
get and the in the uh
vigor of the youthful body
um and i think that's um at least an
option that we want to
uh strongly uh explore
it's so beautifully said that
there's so much hubris in
20 year olds
and then the proper education only you
know once you're 60 you're like i i know
a little bit about the world now yeah
and then now it's and now it's just so
important like you indicated stay
healthy longer keep that that youthful
homeostatic capacity up until your later
years therefore we can be more creative
we can contribute more in our later
years with that mountain of knowledge
that we have later on right very well
said now
oh yeah let's and you're on the advisory
board with sense
that's right and uh
i've uh also a recent startup called
rejuvenate bio which is aimed at using
gene therapy to do aging reversal in
dogs and then
and then move into human clinical trials
with us with the same
um
genes
so hitting this from multiple angles for
longevity now
okay
this is
this this this is
kind of like how we perceive the world
and the mechanisms of which
things work not only this camera system
uh our everything from our phones to uh
all different types of biomaterials that
we see buildings even arcology
architecture
and ecology there's so many interesting
ways to have bio-inspired
materials and robotics and all different
types of things this is what's going on
with you at the um wis institute they
said and i'm pronouncing that right
institute right there we go this
institute which um you're a co-founding
member of
now
teach us about what you're excited about
with the biomaterials
right so
biology
is just another engineering discipline
but it also has some
interesting advantages one advantage is
we have
extremely complex beautifully
uh debugged systems because they've been
debugged over billions of years
over
you know uh
many orders of magnitude of of land and
air and and liquid
we inherit that so that's one thing in
advance the other advantage is we can
redo some of that we can do evolution in
the lab but we could do evolution kind
of on steroids
where we we can accelerate evolution so
we have that
plus we have all the advantages from all
the engineering to other engineering
disciplines like computer aided design
so all these things combined to make
something that's highly accelerated but
we have a fourth thing which is
extremely uh
important and maybe not obvious is that
weak is that we want to atomic we want
we would like to be able to do
atomically precise engineering
if it's free and and basically biology
basically does that it it
almost everything it does is capable of
being atomically precise almost every
molecule is made is the same as every
other molecule of that type
um
and that and it does it at scale so you
can make things the size of a giant
redwood or the size of an entire
ecosystem
and basically for free that forest
didn't really cost us anything
to uh to build so
atomically precise at scale billions of
years evolution
and ability to evolve on our own so
instead of making a prototype in any
other field of engineering like a
prototype for a bridge or a cell phone
where you really put a lot of energy
into one prototype
here you can make a trillion prototypes
and let
evolutionary processes pick best one you
just have to be clever about setting up
the accelerated evolution so this is
interesting the amazing capability of
biology
including materials and it's not just
biologically inspired materials where
you can make atomic precise versions of
things that are normally imprecise
you know like instead of making mortar
we can make a shell
you know with all its intricate patterns
on it mortar is just kind of like blob
of stuff that you smooth out
but we can also make
biology make things that you normally
don't think are biological right not not
shells but but like shells made out of
inorganic materials so we should be able
literally everything we can make metals
semiconductors all of that
we know how to make those with biology
we know how biology can make metals it
can make
it can make um refractive index gradient
or optical fibers
it can
it
it can make thinking machines uh
in fact some of the best super computers
in the world are biologically
manufactured so i i think that nothing
is currently manufactured without
biology is safe
from from uh disruption and revolution
and this is a this is a really good
point for for
young people as well watching is that
there are so many ways for them to to
dive into bio-inspired materials yeah
that's really interesting no matter what
field you've come from
there is
a biological version of that especially
if you're engineer or scientist but i
would say
almost everything
that's societally influenced is also
biologically because society is
a bunch of biological atoms and you come
right down to it
okay george this is
this is crazy you have over 33 years
you've built up a lab the church lab
and your lab has a hundred people now
that
how is this how do you possibly figure
out how to manage this this is
this is important because we have now
we're moving into these
labs at boyden has a really popular now
lab we have more of these labs sort of
popping up with these really roaring
groups of scientists and engineers
intellectuals pushing the boundaries of
knowledge and we want to know how to
best design the the frameworks and the
flows of information in these labs so
you know maybe we start off by asking
you you know here you are
running this lab how do you pick what to
research and how do you delegate
research to other people
yeah well a lot of this has to do with
co-mentoring so
i co-mentor with ed boyden and bob
langer and sangeeta bethia
we we help each other out uh because
we're running kind of similar kinds of
labs
and there's co-mentoring within the lab
uh
you don't
necessarily need a big hierarchy
if you've got a
kind of goodwill
i select for people that are nice i mean
that's one of my yeah first interview
questions is
or discussions is how you achieve that
kind of environment
you you want to have a
an environment where failure is an
option but fail fast if you get on to
the next thing do a bunch of things in
parallel
it's like the lesson of biology is not
to make one prototype but a trillion
prototypes so it's hard to do a trillion
projects but you can at least do more
than one
um
you know have a a
kind of a a real group size of about
three so so the 100 is just a group
bunch of groups of three okay
have interdisciplinary teams see it's
hard to make an anticipated team out of
disciplinarians
so it's easier to make it out of people
that are themselves interdisciplinary so
you have like
two people that know two different
languages even if there's no overlap of
any of those
they uh they know how to gain a third
one so each game a third one is a shared
language and then they can and they can
build up this network of people that are
just then you can decorate it with a few
disciplinarians at the end but
the major network of know-how i think
has to be people who feel comfortable
with two or more fields in their own
head
and this is like molecular biology and
computer science maybe something like
that
or you know
uh philosophy or ethics and and uh and
medicine or
uh you know optics
and genetics for to so you can know the
three-dimensional structure of the of
the genome and et cetera
there's uh and once you get used to it
then it becomes it becomes you're good
at whatever you do and if you have a lab
that does interdisciplinary stuff and
does entrepreneurship and does
um and really generally has its sights
on transformative technology
then something that seems like science
fiction becomes more routine
because that's what you do every day as
you transform things that look hard you
know things are actually easy you don't
want to be actual heroes you just want
to find the low-hanging fruit
and help everybody get to it
there was a couple really important
points there this co-mentorship we've
seen over and over again that mentorship
is such a acceleration of one's fullest
potential into the world so that was a
big one and then also this this
interdisciplinary approach across
we talk about this so much of having
different fields that we're really uh
really knowledgeable in that we can mesh
together and work with other teams it's
these groups of three like you said
within the hundred um and then i really
appreciated how you talked about
entrepreneurship you're actually trying
to translationally take what you're
building at the edge and put that out
into the world and make that available
to people
so crucial
so
how do you keep up how does the lab keep
up and all these labs around the world
now there's the the doubling of
scientific papers is just so fast now
there's
not enough eyeballs to scan them and
understand them how do you keep up
uh well in a way our task is worse speak
harder because we're trying to be
interdisciplinary which we don't know
where the next
um
idiosyncratic oddity from physics or
or
our ethics we could or chemistry could
impact our lab um so we have to
constantly we have to have a lot of
antennae out there so part of the reason
for having a large
interdisciplinary group is that each
individual is an antenna for their
specialties
plural for each person
and they may not be the best in the
world at any particular task some of
them are they're good enough that they
can talk to the the world's experts
so that's one way we don't need
everything because we're mainly doing
this for engineering so we we need
things that are
um
capable of turning into something that
the rest of the world could benefit from
so uh that that that's a luxury
and just in in general when you have a
lot of things working you know a lot of
balls in the air that nobody else has
you're not we're not catching up with
other groups we're kind of staying ahead
and in a way that's
kind of easier yeah in a certain way
it means we'll probably make a few more
mistakes than the average group but uh
but we'll have a lot more warning
um when new things are coming on down
the pipe because a lot of those new
things came from our lab yeah or from
the alumni of our lab
i like the way that you explain this it
has antennas is that you they that you
we got to have the we've got to
constantly be
receiving the the edges across the
different disciplines and plugging it
into what we know george how
with these 500 co-authored publications
and
143 patent publications how are you
ensuring that what you've done
people actually understand and also that
the information in your lab is really
properly being transgenerationally
disseminated right
uh well within the lab it's pretty easy
there's a lot of uh side by side co
mentoring that you can't really can't
get
by books or lectures or that sort of
thing you need to be sitting next to
them uh
day in day out so so that's why these
teams of three uh really uh you know are
are the best way of getting really
complicated things communicated and
and take it to the next step
but there is still a need for educating
the general public and and and and
reverse so it's a conversation it's
two-way
uh
it's a broad societal conversation
because some of these topics um you have
difficult policy components they have
economic components um both people
benefiting from what we do and also us
benefiting from from
from their funding
so so we use various mechanisms one is
uh there's a organization my wife
started called pged.org
tengwu
started in around 2006
and that
has congressional briefings uh every six
months or so for many years now
they work with uh with hollywood for on
tvs and movies which reached millions of
people
both of those mechanisms reach
millions of people
online
materials that that educators high
school educators can just download
um
and then uh
you know working with authors and
journalists in various ways so that that
reaches more people than you can reach
in a simple classroom
it's even more than you can reach with
these web classrooms or very popular
moocs and
things like that and harvard has a great
one called edx
but those don't reach nearly as many
people as you can reach with hollywood
and congress yes and
things like that
as we move forward with figuring out how
to most effectively design
the labs that we can have these hundreds
of scientists ethicists engineers
collaborating and uh and working on the
edge of what's known by society how
would you optimally design the workflows
there you were giving this idea of
mentorship you there's got to be a lab
component there's got to be yeah
entrepreneur component
yeah so i think it was it was hard to
get going and it's not clear that it
would
transfer
trivially it's something where you you
need to have kind of a track record that
attracts the best people because if you
try to
build
you know a soup out of stone soup and
nothing but stones is this problem so so
part of it was a process where first we
inherited the reputation of harvard mit
to attract the best students and
postdocs
but they still didn't believe in what
the lab was doing i mean they would join
they believed it enough to join the lab
but that was
it took another
you know many years to get to the point
where but now we have a track worker
where it both attracts people and they
believe and and the more they believe
the more they accomplish and it's a
positive feedback loop the more they
accomplish the more the next generation
believe they train each other
um
and then and they also
create these entrepreneurship they'll
spin off a company and then the then the
comp the people from the company will
come back
and tell everybody what it's like on the
other side and and they'll it's like uh
older siblings that are like very
protective of the younger ones coming up
through the ranks
and it's just wonderful to watch it
happen because it didn't quite
self-assemble there was some nudging
here and there but for the most part
it's something that's self-sustaining
now yeah and it's uh
and it's slightly amplifying each
generation so you have more and more
alumni out there they kind of they have
this little conspiracy
that they help each other out uh
worldwide and it's it's really wonderful
yeah
that's a
principle of patience and
of providing value and yep and it's been
a long time 33 years so for all the
young people that are really trying to
get to where you're going right away be
patient provide value take your time
getting there
okay a couple quick things on the way
out
uh george what would you say is a core
driving principle of your life
oh well so it's changed over time i
think i had
a kind of
wacky idea what science was like when i
was young
um but i would say that
fairly consistently i've tried to do two
things three things at once okay so any
one of these would be pretty cool but is
as as basic you know science philosophy
philosophically interesting questions
you know like
that would be cool to know
have something that's technological by
fact many factors of 10 not just you
know 1.5 and and broad so it's not just
i'm gonna this is the way you fix a
particular knee problem this is
something that that every everybody can
use like reading and writing dna
uh and then the third thing is having a
society beneficial not just
you know changing society but in in
a way that
there's some consensus on on the on the
value of it so if you can do all three
things you know the basic science the
technological
uh disruption and the societal benefit
that
that's uh it's good and you know it
doesn't have to be medicine it could be
agriculture it could be um
you know data storage you can be getting
off the planet getting some of us off
the planet to
have a backup all these things are
you don't have to prioritize perfectly
um you certainly don't want to put all
your tips on one thing that you think is
the world's most important problem you
want to have a diverse portfolio for the
world and even for each individual
yeah oh those are that was so
beautifully said love it um
this wouldn't be simulation if we didn't
ask you um
do you think this is a simulation
um
you know
i think simple answer is i don't know uh
i think that if it doesn't really matter
to some extent because in the simulation
we need to be doing something uh
you know
i
i doubt it personally uh but it you know
it would if it is it's such a
sophisticated one that we might as well
live out that in that simulation
we may be the only intelligence in the
planet in the universe
and we better take it seriously there's
some reason why we're the only
intelligence in that universe
george is like the video game character
that
maxed out all of his attributes
especially in the field of biology
thank you
um okay last question george um what is
the most beautiful thing in the world
the most beautiful thing you know you
know no one's ever asked me that
question in an interview uh
um so i'll give a very spontaneous
answer but i would i would say the
way that we uh
know about the world is the way we gain
knowledge and
and uh think about the past and the
future is very is really quite beautiful
i mean it's it's it's what makes us
human if we took away if we changed
ourselves in many ways so we're
unrecognizable visually
sound different
if we can still do that that's a
beautiful thing and that's and that's
the thing that will allow another beaut
a beautiful thing it's related to is our
ability to survive that's that's the
darwinian beauty of the world um
but our ability to know is is is one of
the most potent ways of of
we we can survive and all the
things we we bring along with us
thank you george this has been an honor
and a pleasure thank you thank you so
much for your continued work in this
field at the edge and inspiring others
oh thank you thank you for coming on the
show and joining us really appreciate it
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate you go ahead and give us your
thoughts in the comments below on all
things related to biology like we've
been discussing with george we'd love to
hear from you
also go and build go and build manifest
your dreams into the world everyone go
creatively execute we love you so much
thank you for tuning in also check out
all of the great links below to
georgia's work into the labs work at
church lab and also join us at
simulation so we can help scale this
content to more people and come on site
to great places and talk to some of the
world's most brilliant leaders we
greatly appreciate you much love and
we'll see you soon
peace